लुट नमस्कार आपका स्वागत है जर्मन सीखिए
हिंदी में के नए एपिसोड में आज हम एक बहुत
ही इंपोर्टेंट कंसेप्ट सीखने जाने वाले
हैं मॉडल व तो आइए शुरू करते हैं तो सबसे
पहले हम समझते हैं कि मोड ऑल वर्क्स किया
है तो यह मोड ऑन वर्ष ऐसे वर्ड्स है जो
आपकी क्रिया नहीं बताते और उसकी जरूरत है
उसकी पॉसिबिलिटी बताते हैं एक अगर उद्धारक
लें तो आई प्ले क्रिकेट मैं अभी क्रिकेट
में खेल रहा हूं पर जब मैं बोलता हूं कि
आई कैन प्ले क्रिकेट तब मैं बोलता हूं कि
मेरे में क्रिकेट खेलने की क्षमता है जब
मैं बोलता हूं कि आयुष्मण प्ले क्रिकेट तो
मैं बोल रहा हूं कि मुझे मेरे लिए क्रिकेट
खेलना अच्छा है तो यह जो सारे कैन स्पेंड
मच गुड नाइट टू यह जो सारे वर्ड्स है इनको
बोलते हैं मॉडल पर कि यह आपके वर्ष को
हेल्प कर
कि मैं उनको एक्स्ट्रा इन्फॉर्मेशन देते
हैं अगर आप देखेंगे तो हिंदी में यह किसी
भी भारतीय भाषा में यह थोड़े से क्रिस्ट
है तो अगर आप देखोगे मैं क्रिकेट खेलना
चाहता हूं मुझे क्रिकेट खेलना चाहिए इसमें
आपको अलग-अलग तरीके से इसको बनाना पड़ता
है पर लकी अली यूरोपीयन लैंग्वेजेस में यह
इजी है तो इसीलिए यह जो पॉइंट है यह हम
इंग्लिश की मदद से सीखेंगे तो हम कैसे
सीखेंगे अब हम देखते हैं तो एकदम सिंपल
सेंटेंस लेते हैं इंग्लिश का वीएस रोल
प्ले करके वीरू प्ले करें तो इसका जर्मन
कैसे होगा पहला विटी देखते हैं विशेष रूप
ले क्रिकेट का यह जो लंदन क्रिकेट पिलर
व्ययन क्रिकेट पी लें अगर आप देखोगे तो
बोलते हैं हमें पता है
क्रिकेट तो क्रिकेट रहेगा सूट को झूलन
होते हैं झन बोलते हैं और प्ले को बोलते
हैं यह हमको पता है तू प्ले आज भी न तो
पुलिस का किराया छोड़कर धन आया क्रिकेट का
टिकट कटाया प्ले एक छोटी सी चीज अलग हुई
इंग्लिश में कैंडी क्रश प्ले लिस्ट प्ले
स्पिनर था वह में जोनल क्रिकेट यह जो व था
इसके बारे में बात करने वाले थे वह और
अपने मूल रूप में नियुक्त जोनल क्रिकेट
विश्वकप फुटबॉल
हेलो व्यूअर्स अंकुश विलेन विशुद्ध टेनिस
वीर विसजर्न इंपोर्टेंट चीज है अभी चेक
करके देखते हैं विषय जरुर यह जो लंदन
विश्व दृष्टि वीरवार को पोजीशन आएगा और जो
है वह क्लियर सबको यह पहले हम तीन स्टेप
में पहले क्लियर है और इसको अब जैसे होता
है वैसे भी वह आता है
मोहित कहर कैंप को बोलते हैं क्यों न हों
उसके बाद छोटी सी इच्छा है अ गुड नाइट डू
समथिंग छोटी सी इच्छा इसको बोलते हैं
सिस्टम में अष्टम आपको कुछ करने की अनुमति
मिली टू डू समथिंग यूनीक मे तो यहां पर
आपको कोई चीज करना कंपलसरी यू मस्ट बे
बिज़ी इन जर्मन मिर्च और आपको कुछ करने की
मन से बहुत बड़ी इच्छा है कि मुझे यह मुझे
एस्ट्रोनॉट बनना ही है आई वांट टू बिकम
समथिंग हम फिर से 66 से देखते हैं आप मेरे
साथ हो
कि शौर्य मतलब हर न कैन मतलब क्यों न
कि चोटी सी इच्छा वुड लाइक टू इज मिनिस्टर
में अलग-2 इस डिफाइन थिस मस्ट इस मिशन
डोंट टू इस वजन भी बाकी सब तो सेम रहेगा
तो क्रिकेट के साथ यह सब करके देखते हैं
पहले हमने क्या देखा था विशुद्ध प्ले
क्रिकेट यह ज्वेलरी क्रिकेट पिलर विच कैन
एफ्लिक्ट व्यक्तियों ने क्रिकेट की सबसे
ज्यादा बढ़ा दो
प्ले लिस्ट प्ले क्रिकेट खेला तो अच्छा है
यह न्यूनतम क्रिकेट लाइव क्रिकेट स्कोर
क्रिकेट खेल लौंडे आज मयूर पंख क्रिकेट
चैनल
कि हमें क्रिकेट खेलना है पड़ेगा बी मस्ट
प्ले क्रिकेट वीर्य मिशन क्रिकेट खेल
को भी वांट टू प्ले क्रिकेट वेयर वॉर्न
इक्वेस्ट्रियन सबको जो भी आपका मॉडल व है
वह सेकंड पोजिशन पर रहेगा मीन व भिंडी में
लास्ट परेशान करेगा यह हो गए दूसरा स्थित
अब तीसरा ऑप्शन है तो देख को जैसे हमने
देखा था हावर और त्यौहारों और लाइक या थे
कि रेगुलर वर्ग थे मतलब जो पहला वाला
हफ्ता इस क्रीम को दूध और इससे वह मानते
नहीं थे वह वैसे ही यह भी irregular से यह
जो सारे जेवर बाद हम सीख सकें वह सारे
रेगुलर है और उनका टेबल आप स्क्रीन पर देख
सकते हो
मैं अभी एक चीज आप कर सकते हो कि हम लोग
तो रक्त हमारी सकते हैं तो आप यह टेबल का
पूरा रखा मार सकते हो इस कानों-कान चेहरे
जी का लगे वग़ैरा वग़ैरा वग़ैरा पर मैं
आपको यह ट्रिक देता है अगर आपको इजी बनाने
के लिए और एनीव्हेयर आप इतनी बार यूज करने
वाले होंगे थोड़े दिन बाद आप अपने आप इसका
अनमोल ने लघु पर शुरुआत में यह इतना बड़ा
टेबल याद करने से अच्छा है कि मैं आपको यह
ट्रिक देता तो इसमें से जो हेयर है तुम
दोनों यह इतना यूज नहीं करते किसी ने अपने
क्लास में भी यह नहीं पड़ा था तो अभी के
दूसरे को थोड़ा सा जुड़ते हैं तो फिर है
क्या गया इस दो एयर बेस जी
ऑन कर पांच अभी अगर आप शांति से कांस्टेबल
को देखो तो सबसे पहले कान का अगर आप टेबल
देखो कि उनका तो आप देखोगे पहला और तीसरा
पहला और तीसरा इश्क और जो है दोनों काम है
इस बीच काम है एफबी अकाउंट है सिर्फ दो को
टेस्टी लगा है धूप कारण शुक्रवार और दिया
और जी वह तो इंफिनिटिव में रहते हैं हर
जगह क्यों न तो अगर अपने एक जोड़ी याद
रखिए कारण क्यों न तो आपको यह सब याद
रहेगा तो
कि कैसे और उसको तोड़ना कैसे जोड़ी को
कार्यों उनका पहला और तीसरा कारण ही दूसरे
में स्टीव लगाओ भी 4G क्यों न कहना क्यों
नहीं वैसे अगर आप देखोगे जोनाथन के लिए इस
और धूल धूप को दोस्त है वीर और चीज अनुकूल
है अगर आप वजन को जाओ इस और एल्बम मिल है
धूप के लिए स्टे लगाओ विसनीय और अधीन फिर
से वजन है तो आप देखोगे यह पैटर्न हर जगह
लोग तो इसकी मैं कुछ जोड़ियां देता हूं
कुछ यह चूड़ियां मतलब 12 व सिर्फ 12
वर्ल्ड पढ़ो आपको सारे मोडल भर वाले सिंपल
है तो सिलेक्ट यह छह जोड़ियां फिर से
देखते हैं
एक दम झलक
के कान तो कुंदन मिस्टर मिस्टर दार दिव्य
फल पुष्प विल लर्न और कैसे इस और कि
युवकों के लिए स्टे लगा दिया और के लिए
क्यों बोल रहे हो
कि यह सब को अब इसका यूज देखते हैं हम
कैसे करना 5 सेंटेंस देखते हैं तो आपको यह
आसान हो जा
है तो सबसे पहले बेसिक से शुरू करते हैं
अभी भी फोन में ही रहते हैं कि
थे व्हिप इट पिसर
कि वीर्य ज्वेलरी पिज़्ज़ा एडिसन
सर्कुलेशन पर सोलर सिस्टम एंड वे मस्ट टीच
र न्यू सल मे ज़रूर रहस्य कंडीशन में
क्लियर क्लियर है थोड़ा करते जाते हैं इस
सपोर्ट मुझे बोलना है मस्ट प्ले लिस्ट
प्ले करो और चलेगा क्या मस्त चलेगा और
मिशन के में क्या है इस माउस एंड
सब्सक्राइब नहीं चलाना है उसको चला है कि
मैं अपने हिंदी में बोलते हो मैं क्रिकेट
खेलता हूं तुम क्रिकेट खेलते हो पर जब आप
बोलते हो मैं क्रिकेट खेल सकता हूं अपने
सकता है
आंखें कुछ छोड़ दिया अब ऐसे नहीं बोलते
मैं क्रिकेट खेलता सकता हूं तुम क्रिकेट
खेलते सकते हो खेल मैं और रूकमिनी रहा
वैसे ही जर्मन में इस हो दूर वह पिलर एंड
में इंफिनिटिव में ही रहेगा फिर से आई
मस्ट प्ले क्रिकेट या मस्ट प्ले टेनिस
इसमें स्टेट मिनिस्टीरियल यू मस्ट प्ले
क्रिकेट दूर मोस्ट टेनिस और हुई ए मस्ट
प्ले क्रिकेट न्यूज़ पेपर
ए प्लेयर अभी सबको अब ऐसे रैंडमली आपके मन
में जितने कोई भी सेंटेंस बना सकते हो और
जैसे कि वे लीड बर्गर वीर 1512 रिंग को
वजन को तीन चम्मच दो
तो प्लीज जर्मन इस मुसलमान को बोलते दो
इष्ट स्मूद और डिप्रेशन सिंपल है आप कितने
भी सेंटेंसेस से बना सकते हो जितने
सेंटेंस आप बनाओगे उतना आपके लिए इस युद्ध
जाए तो चलिए हम एक बार फिर से यह तीनों
सेट कर रिवीजन करते हैं तो आपके लिए इजी
हो का यह पहली लिस्ट सबसे पहले हमने क्या
शिकार मॉडल व क्या है ऐसे भर जो आपकी
क्रिया नहीं बताते बल्कि सक्रिय की जरूरत
क्या है यह पॉसिबल टीम वह बताते हैं कैंट
रोड मस्ट में वांट टो एक्सेप्ट तो उसका
कैसे करना है पहले तो ऑलमोस्ट इंग्लिश की
तरह ही वी कैन विजिट प्ले क्रिकेट का
बीयर्स अंतरिक्ष की जाएंगे इंपोर्टेंट
क्या है सिर्फ रन स्किन एंड मिल जाएगा और
जरूरत सर्कुलेशन कर
थे सेकंड स्टेप में हमने क्या सिखा दौरान
जैसे के अंदर फंड में रिटर्न में स्थल वजन
है और थर्ड स्टेप मुझे बोला एक तो आप पूरा
टेबल याद करो या अपने आप आपको इससे
अप्रेंटिस का जायदा पर अभी के लिए हमने
जोड़ी ऐसी की खोज में लंका कांड कर्णधार
दर्पण वेस्टमिंस्टर ने मुख्य मिशन एंड विल
वॉर्डन ठीक है फिर हमारा देश उसके है
सेकेंड पोजीशन पर मोड व जाएगा और वह चलेगा
नुव्वे नुव्वे रिलेटिव आफ थिस सेंटेंस याद
रख सकते हो आईएस मस्ट प्ले क्रिकेट टेस्ट
मैच क्रिकेट पिलर ठीक है मुझे आशा है कि
आपको यह मोड वर्क एपिसोड समझ में आया होगा
अगर आपको कुछ कोई भी डाउट है तो प्लीज
कमेंट में लिखिए अगर आपको क्लियर नहीं है
तो और एक बार यह एपिसोड देखिए पर जब तक यह
क्लियर नहीं हो आगे मत पढ़िए क्योंकि यह
बहुत
इंपोर्टेंट है अगर आपको मडाल वर्ग आते हैं
तो आपको फ्यूचर टेंस भविष्य का और
रिक्वेस्ट फ्री में मिल जाते हैं वह कैसे
हम नेक्स्ट पार्ट्स में देखेंगे पर लिटरली
जिसको घड़ा भर जाता है उसको फीचर और
रिक्वेस्ट अपने आप आ जाते हैं इसीलिए मोड
व थिस वन ऑफ द मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट कंसर्ट्स
अगर इसमें टाइम लगता है तो लीजिए कोई भी
डोंट है तो कमेंट में पूछे है मैं उनके
आंसर देने की कोशिश करूंगा एक बार समझ में
नहीं आए तो बार-बार कीजिए अपने अपने छोटे
सेंटेंसेस लिखिए बढ़ते हैं यह बहुत ही इजी
है अगर आप तीन स्टेप ठीक से फॉलो करोगे तो
वह बहुत आसान है मुझे आशा है कि आपको यह
ऑल वर्क एपिसोड आ पसंद आया होगा और समझ
में भी आया होगा हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
एपिसोड ने धन्यवाद है